こんにちははじめ社長です
お前また来たのかと言われたらそこまで
ですけどまた来ました事故物件に泊まって
みよう
ップメジャー肇社長です以前持ち込むきて
に泊まってみたんですけども今回この物件
で撮影していきたいとおもいます前回の
動画見てなぜ here成底買ったんです
けども今回はもっとすごいですよ在り方が
すごいというか衛生 d な部分では前回
よりかなりやばいです早速なんですけども
夕方のうつに一通り見ていきましょうか
違う普通に入口ですねなんか落ちてたん
でしょこれはもうかなり昔に使われてたん
だろうなって感じ絶対指の跡だよね
ちょっと
外装歩きせないんでなんかだけになります
けども
ちょっと光
何者と怖いんだけど
ちょっと見ていきましょうか今れは
ええええ軽いうちに見れるとかみましょう
この図と言えねぇ
ああああまで bot ね坊どんな感じの
トイレです低俗守り抜きたらいう待って
待って
ん
何
分
何な生き物生き物なのそれそういう勢い後
てしまーすちょっと部屋で入れます
かなり広々とした部屋ですね特にえっと
汚いですねこれ
誇りなにこれ
待ってネズミじゃねえだろ a 女なんで
こんなど真ん中人のてか
ええもうれ無理なんだけど普通に
とりあえずさあの取りますが頑張って作家
ば木は切ってんだよねそこ鳥の羽みたいな
も剃ってる失礼しますここがまあ代どころ
かなん
[拍手]
料理しようとは思わない電気配線も方に古
そうですねでここが
青袋田絶対変ないなんか基づきたくないし
言うかをべコンってなっちゃってるのか
もういや無理だな胸により同ありますが
開けてみましょうか
ua底抜け取る待ってこれ俺あるかどう
する危なくない普通に仲いいの
です
エメリーバコバコボール箱言ってこれはベ
ローンと古い高架下二弾ですねああ
いきますきたなぁ外だ
どーん
moon
なんか木のいい匂いをしますがうんん
妊娠し
2回行きました
[音楽]
ここもこっちもトイレかな
プー大江ってこっちぐうううあー
あー商事ももボコボコだ多くがそんなに
広くはないですねただやっぱりなんか
そんなに荒れますってくらいいろんなもの
がぼろぼろになっている印象を受けます
あれ方がね前回のを宇宙にかなり荒れて
ます
謎のあのねぇ見てるとなく不安になりまし
たはいという理由って
拠点はにないかなと思うで活動していき
たいと思います1階はもうしがいがあった
ので2にも厭世的にやは一応管理者の方
からあまりに羽化が汚すぎるんで土足でも
ok っていうことをいただいているので
土足で歩かせていただきます
時刻00時43分
そうする深夜の1時になります暗くなって
から直物件徘徊していないのでこの一月が
変わった瞬間に改めて事故物件見ていき
たいとおもいますいきましょうでは見て
いきましょうか
もう床が汚すぎて絶対衛生上町のメタモン
で今日は押入れで寝ますいやほんとこう
いう国家のてが中このキラキラ猫はええ
ええええ
まあ2回はずっといたんでそんな大きな
変化はない気もしますが問題は
からですよ
ちっちゃのオーラやべー
ちょっと何が待っているのか
イバ
二つ作ってみましょう
じゃあ俺パックるっていうねにくい3から
さ
あと日
ラッカー甲
何これ言うかの反対ことば
かいうきっ
サッシ
わからないが落書きみたいのがありました
なんか気づかんかっとくらいと新しくね
いろいろな気づきそうな気がします
1回おりました
fa
円は強いず浴槽とかをもう絶対入らないか
な俺を競ってクライネはそっぽ向けの部屋
ですね
いやー相変わらず危なくてちょっと
渡れないの
絶対ないわマジで動画にならなかったらや
だからん
さすがに無理たとして俺ね
何なんだろうねぇさあ一番広い広場です
[音楽]
特に何かあるわけではありませんが降っ
とるに梅雨明けなかったんだけどこれ気に
なるように
ちょっと開けますさぁ声
う
なるほどねたぶん何から纏ってあったん
でしょ
me
f 確認腕したもあるん
塩を受けるとき開けましょうん
[拍手]
あかんがヤバイ片瀬きて
あやばい開いたなにその脇方そんな気がし
ないでしょ普通にそれが効かと
なんかも
いや何もないけど2作光学山ここにさ指
かけて意味わかんねえんだよこの秋彼と
ずっと中級者なってるしもう
いうかは汚いし
特に後はと絵ですねー
[音楽]
大丈夫そうかな先生の
1個いいですか
自分がすごいくっていうのかな絶対来でき
ないんですよ俺失礼だと今日怖いんです
間違えて恋しいもうくれるんですけど
意外といきますあとは札だけかな
自分をおやすみなさい
寒いその入れを寝ないと
うわぁ手袋入りましたこんなに稼働するに
入れません
あったかやったから全然駄目そう
おやすみ
ん
[音楽]
yeah
ああああああ
my love ございます
ムース生きてるの0う
うーん
上が起きてましたでしょうかねた画像庫を
定かじゃないんですけどかなりなんかネル
ギーア苦しい環境があって気がします
ちょっと実際に何が起きてったかと変わっ
てるん寝てる間はわかんなかったしたこと
ですネズミが神殿のば本当に純粋には言葉
ねカーっていう衛生的になって苦しさが
あったっていう方が寒い付くらいでしたね
いやだけで雰囲気がすごいんでほんとねー
3回にも1そうですね
ben
んあっ
[音楽]
はーる
eleanor
[音楽]